transhumanism is an intellectual
movement discussing and oftentimes
promoting the enhancement of The Human
Condition through technology
the resulting post-human could be
stronger than any person on Earth right
now they could be faster they might age
at a slower rate if at all perhaps
through genetic modification perhaps
through advancements in robotic
Prosthetics they might have full control
over their physical appearance being
able to fully Express who they are on
the inside through their biological form
or perhaps they would not be biological
at all but exist as disembodied engrams
uploaded to the cloud
ghosts in the machine
maybe they could communicate
telepathically via brain implants
through exocortices their cognitive
abilities might be beyond our
understanding
such a being might come to regard human
1.0 as we think of a chimpanzee only
this time that Evolution would have been
self-directed this has always had an
undeniable appeal to me it's why
transhumanism was the subject of my
dissertation augmenting the human body
through technology might seem like the
next step for a technologically advanced
civilization but I believe it to be
hubris
I think it would end in ruin of course
there are economic sociological
psychological and even existential
issues to contend with what happens when
only certain people can afford the
enhancements needed to succeed in life
What Becomes of our Humanity when we can
alter our emotions of will where do we
draw the line as to what's acceptable
but there is a much deeper more
fundamental issue to consider the fact
that perhaps the human body simply
cannot be improved upon not by us not
yet
you might point to the incredible
examples of robotic limbs controlled by
the mind or perhaps examples of
seemingly impossible neural networks
simulating animal brains on a computer
maybe you'd explained that we can
already create extremely muscular beings
through myostatin blocking Gene
modification and the resultant double
muscling it brings
perhaps you're impressed by what you've
seen from neuralink but all of these
examples are extremely flawed our
understanding of the human body is so
laughably limited that we could not
possibly hope to improve on it in any
meaningful way right now
the best way to start significantly
improving ourselves right now is by
adopting beneficial habits and making
them a part of our routine that's where
today's sponsor fabulous comes in the
number one self-care app to help you
build better habits and achieve your
goals fabulous is a habit tracking app
that employs Concepts from Behavioral
Science to help you adopt new habits and
stick with them alternatively take part
in Journeys that immerse you in a
personalized Adventure over several
weeks these include motivational letters
and challenges to help you improve your
lifestyle in meaningful ways it's a
digital coach in your pocket you can
also get support and ideas from the
community of over 30 million users via
circles I use fabulous to keep track of
these shorter movements and incidental
workouts that I like to do throughout
the day as well as to remind me to use
my brain training app biomind among
other things new habits and routines are
meaningless until we actually stick with
them and that makes fabulous an
extremely powerful tool teacher amount
of fish and all that start building your
ideal daily routine the first 100 people
who you click the link below we'll get
25 off their fabulous subscription
thanks again to Fabulous for sponsoring
this video and now on with the show
yes there are robotic limbs that can be
controlled by the Mind perhaps they
could be given the strength to crush
Rock and steal for their dexterity
sensory feedback and fine motor control
pales in comparison to that of even a
clumsy toddler
simply picking up a spoon and bringing
it to your face requires an incredible
dance of tiny muscles in constant
communication with the brain each of
those tiny muscles engages just the
right number of motor units to deliver
just the right amount of power the
fascia tightens to send signals to other
distant muscles helping to operate
countless built-in reflexes we didn't
even recognize the importance of fascia
until very recently we are light years
from being able to reproduce this kind
of fine movement there can be no Winter
Soldier no RoboCop
the brain is even more complex attempts
to map neural networks in computers are
in my opinion ultimately doomed to
failure the brain is not a static map it
is constantly shifting and changing
neuroplasticity that occurs in the span
of milliseconds may be responsible for
functions as fundamental as working
memory our brain is constantly
reorganizing and growing forming new
connections and we don't understand the
laws that govern this process we don't
know the true purpose of white matter
though it outweighs gray matter
considerably we don't entirely know the
rules that govern which
neurotransmitters are released when in
the brain or where there are likely many
we have yet to discover even none of
which is to mention the absolutely
integral interplay between the body and
the mind the way in which hormones and
neurotransmitters produced in the gut
and elsewhere can affect cognition the
way that as embodied cognition
postulates we may require a physical
experience in order to grasp any
concepts at all we cannot improve on
these bodies with technology but perhaps
we're getting ahead of ourselves perhaps
there's another step we can focus on
maybe our focus should instead be on
taking full advantage of the bodies we
have right now because I believe that
there is a huge amount of potential
untapped within us I believe that the
human body is truly the final frontier
and I'm not talking about
self-improvement or getting fitter I'm
talking about unlocking a step change in
human performance by better
understanding our biology I believe that
we can find ways one day to discover
huge amounts of additional physical
prowess strength agility and speed
perhaps by gaining greater conscious
control over our motor units I believe
we can optimize our diets and Lifestyles
to live for longer but I think that the
most profound change will come from
changing the way we think
and I call this Max humanism
if it sounds far-fetched then consider
just what we know the body to be capable
of already consider that the blind can
learn to see with sonar using the
tremendous adaptability of the human
brain
imagine if we taught ourselves a new
language that was more efficient
allowing for greater data processing
imagine if we could utilize technology
to provide greater Fidelity and sensory
feedback to transform the way we
understand our own bodies during
training and help draw our attention to
Tiny Sensations that already exist thus
greatly expanding their potential
through further plasticity
or for useful divert your reality to
drop ourselves into impossible training
scenarios that challenged Us in new ways
what if we could find a more efficient
way to consume information flooding our
brains with huge amounts of data in
weeks or days and becoming Adept in
countless skills not using technology to
augment the body then but rather to
better train it and eke out the most
incredible performance possible
I believe we're capable of much more and
that this should be our Focus instead of
trying to become more than human we
should aim to become more human
okay so that was a thing I hope you
enjoyed that little ramble if it all
sounds a little grandiose keep in mind
here that my motivation is strictly to
be more like Spider-Man
strictly childish but I do believe that
there's a lot of untapped potential
within us and that we are much further
from being able to effectively augment
our bodies than we think we are and how
we achieve this step change well
obviously I haven't quite cracked that
code just yet but that's what a lot of
my research and exploration is actually
about I have some cool ideas and I've
found some cool information I'm going to
be sharing that over the coming months
so stay tuned and look out for a video
on super Intelligence coming soon so
what do you guys think do you like the
term Max humanism do you think it has
any Merit let me know below and if
you're interested in training both the
body and mind in ways that go beyond
simply losing weight or increasing your
numbers on a few lifts then check out my
program super functional training 2.0
Link in the description either way thank
you so much for watching this one
and bye for now